[SOUND OF DOOR OPENING AND CLOSING]
Hello, and welcome to the new flat.
So, moving in here, I am having to buy all new
furniture,
which has been really fun, actually,
but I am also finding that my priorities are maybe
a little skewed in terms of what I want to buy when.
For example, right now I can't stop thinking
about buying
the Philips Hue Light Bulbs, you know,
the really expensive ones
that connect to the Wi-Fi and you can pick any
color from your phone.
I still haven't got a dining table yet.
I haven't got anywhere to eat, and I'm thinking
about that.
I even went through the effort of counting
all of the light bulbs and
figuring out how much it would cost me
to trick out this entire flat with Wi-Fi lights.
£2,100. I'm not gonna do it. I need to buy
somewhere to eat first.
First? I'm not going to do it at all.
Don't do it, Charlie. Don't do it.
And just so we're completely clear, no, it's not
product placement.
Obviously it's not. If it was, I'd have the light bulbs,
wouldn't I.
I do really want the design of this place to be
as nice as I can get it, though.
Like the amount of effort I put into figuring out like
where the mugs were going to go in relation to
the kettle and the tea bags and the fridge
to make it so that when you make tea, it involves
as little movement as possible.
It's just kind of obsessive, in a worrying way, really.
Also, speaking of tea...ahh!
See, that's what product placement looks like.
QualiTea mugs I'll put a link in the description
if you'd like one.
And again on design obsessiveness,
I made the inside of this white
even though I'll be making less money off
of these because of that.
Because I know that when you make tea,
it's easier to tell the strength of tea when the
inside is white.
So, I'm really hoping my love for tea shines
through in these things.
I've also revamped the design of the QualiTea
T-shirts so that they match the mugs now,
so you can get one of those too, and that's the
end of my sales pitch.
Thanks for putting up with it.
So my list of new furniture that I have managed
to acquire so far are my sofa, by bed,
and my mattress
all of which have presented their own
various problems.
With both the sofa and the bed, I did decide
to assemble them by myself
even though they both clearly said in the
instructions they took
two or three people to make, but I've always seen that
as less of a requirement and more of a challenge.
And with the mattress, the poor delivery man
had to do
quite a lot of bending and squeezing to pack
that thing into the lift and get it up here
that by the time he finally did drop the thing off
in the bedroom,
he looked at me just like completely exhausted,
and he said,
"Whenever you get lucky on this thing,
please think of me."
And the worst part is that I did once,
and it was just briefly, but all the same.
Thanks for the mattress, though.
Generally, though, my experience of living here
so far has been absolutely lovely.
My favorite thing being that for some reason
in this apartment complex,
there are a lot of cats just sort of roaming free.
There was genuinely this one time when I was
on my way out,
and a little cat followed me into the lift on the
my down.
And to start with, I was kind of worried.
I was like,
"Is this okay? Am allowed to be taking this cat
down with me?"
But then I looked at the little guy, and he was like
so chill about the whole thing.
We got to the ground floor, the doors opened,
he just sauntered out, and I thought two things
Firstly: that cat has probably ridden that lift more
times than I have.
He's more comfortable doing it than me.
And secondly: I just rid in a lift with a cat.
How cool is that?
Dude, I've got like three other things to talk about,
but I feel like I'm already going to cut a lot
of stuff out of this,
so I guess I'll see you next time.
I've had a busy week. That's nice.
Anyway, goodbye.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
Thank you very much for watching.
Here's my previous video just in case you missed it.
I mean, yes, at its core, the video is just a list of
five films that I watched,
but there is a bit more to it than that, I promise.
I tried to do a list with a bit more depth.
I'm really not selling this thing. That's fine.
It means you'll go in with low expectations,
and then it will be really great or you won't
click on it all, which is also fine.
I can live with that. At least I tried.
Okay, bye!
SILENCE